dead Tucson today Ronnie lipstick is
testing a Tucson Hyundai has produced a
compact SUV since 2005 a Korean model
with an American name like Tucson
Arizona that's built in the Czech
Republic and designed by a German that's
true globalization Hyundai named the
second generation of this crossover
model the ix35 and many markets but the
current third generation is known as the
Tucson pretty much everywhere
the SUV hits the streets with a striking
new design and more self-confidence and
it's great fun to drive we're testing
the version with the style equipment
package Ronnie says the two sons no
featherweight depending on the engine
and trim level it can weigh up to 1.7
tons but then Hyundai wasn't aiming to
build a lightweight vehicle but rather a
robust compact SUV that's also good on
long hauls
he thinks the Tucson does that quite
well
at the front the crossovers striking
design can't be overlooked the large
hexagonal radiator grille that's typical
for Hyundai models and the new LED
headlights are both real attention
getters
from the side the two Sun also cuts a
good figure the gradually rising window
line and the black cladding over the
wheel wells at a touch of sportiness
at the rear the most eye-catching
feature is the horizontal taillights but
the twin tailpipes also add to the
overall impression
compared to the second generation the
new Tucson Bo's 10% more cargo space it
can hold 513 liters or around 1500
liters with the rear seats folded down
so there's plenty of room among the two
sons driver assists are an automatic
emergency braking system which combines
radar and camera data to detect that the
car ahead makes a sudden stop the two
top trim lines style and premium both
come equipped with a rear view camera as
well as the smart Park Assist the style
version also features a lane departure
warning system
Feli mommy says there are many
adjustments that can be made in the
Tucson you can lock the center
differential because we have all-wheel
drive and there's a button to adjust the
steering there are two modes sport and
normal Ronnie doesn't think there's much
difference between the two though
steering might be a bit stiffer in sport
mode relized mini machetes lightning
sport models
black dominates the car's interior the
center console is well laid out and
pepped up a little by the piano black
details the infotainment system is
clearly arranged and easy to use thanks
to its touchscreen and buttons the
leather steering wheel feels good in
your hands and has just a few buttons to
control the radio and the dashboard
display and though the seats aren't
leather they're two-toned fabric looks
sharp
the Tucson comes with a choice of eight
engines five diesel and three
gasoline-powered our test model is
fitted with a 136 kilowatt diesel engine
the most powerful one on offer it
propels the Tucson from 0 to 100 km/h
and around 10 seconds top speed is 202
km/h and fuel consumption is
surprisingly low for an SUV of this size
just 6.5 liters per 100 kilometers
Mutulu mommy says with the two son
Hyundai was one of the first car makers
to introduce a compact SUV the segment
so popular that other automakers have
followed suit so the competition keeps
growing he thinks the Hyundai Tucson
will stay a contender in this segment
for a while to come